so can you guarantee that the UK is
gonna leave the EU by the 31st of
October yes that's our determined policy
we know that the European Union want us
to leave we know that we have a deal
that allows us to leave and listening to
Labour MPs like Lucy who are very
honorably wants to make sure that the
referendum mandate is fulfilled there is
now an opportunity with a good deal and
people just a few weeks ago we're saying
that we'd be impossible for the Prime
Minister to get this deal but number 10
was saying that well one of the things
that the Prime Minister has shown is
that determined and focused negotiation
can ensure that we honor the referendum
mandate and people were saying that
withdrawal agreement couldn't be
reopened it has been people were saying
that the backstop couldn't be ditched it
has been people were saying that we
wouldn't be able to get the United
Kingdom hold an entire to leave the
European Union it's there and I hope
that in the days ahead
MPs like my friend amber rod and Lucy
Powell who indicated that they they want
to get brexit done will ensure that we
do so in a timely and orderly way I
can't help but notice my answers you can
guarantee that we're gonna leave at the
end of October you said that's our
determined policy which I kind of feel
is a little bit different no we are
going to leave by October the 31st we
have the means and the ability to do so
and people who you know yesterday we had
some people who voted for delay voted
explicitly to try to frustrate to this
process and to drag it out I think
actually the mood in the country is
clear and the Prime Minister's
determination is absolute and I am with
him in this we must leave by October
31st but you sent a letter and I know
that you can say that you sent other
letters as well but the Prime Minister
didn't sign it that it was a photocopy
or whatever but you have still sent a
letter requesting an extension to the EU
so how can you sit here and say that you
can guarantee that we're going to leave
by the 31st I understand that letter was
sent because Parliament required it to
be sent but as David Davis pointed items
as David Davis pointed out earlier
Parliament can insist that a letter was
sent but Parliament can't change the
Prime Minister's mind Parliament can't
change the government's policy or
determination and the Prime Minister is
very clear and
and for that matter so a European Union
leaders they want this done and we I
think as a parliament we had an
opportunity yesterday to send a
determined signal collectively that we
wanted it done we now have an
opportunity in the days ahead to pass
the legislation necessary in order to
ensure that we honor the referendum
mandate and leave so happy hard
assurances then from EU leaders that
they are gonna veto an extension well
I'm not going to talk about
conversations that may or may not have
been had with EU leaders but I think it
would be wrong for people to assume as
some do the EU leaders want this to drag
out
Emmanuel macron Leo vodka and others
have said they want this done by the
31st of October there's there's no
profit in delay for anyone the European
Union wants to move on it wants to make
sure that we can have the next stage of
our relationship develop and and also
there's no one in this country who
thinks do you know what the last three
and a half years I want that division
and I want that uncertainty to persist
we need to get this done so I just want
to just try to pin down what's gonna be
happening so when are you expecting your
response from the EU well I think the
first thing is the EU are waiting to see
what Parliament does now so I think that
there are many in Europe who were
disappointed that Parliament didn't vote
clearly yesterday any meaningful votes
to leave will have an opportunity in the
days ahead to consider the legislation
that allows us to leave the European
Union if people vote for that
legislation as as ambos suggested Mr
Rudd suggested that you would and as
lucy and many other Labour MPs may well
do then we can leave and we can leave in
time so just to be clear if in the
coming days Parliament votes to approve
the deal does that mean the letter is
withdrawn yes if we if we if we vote to
leave if we get the legislation through
then there is no extension October 31st
is within sight is that all of the
legislation or is that just the
meaningful vote that many expect it's
going to be happening tomorrow
it's the legislation we work well the
critical thing is were introducing this
legislation Parliament can get it done
Parliament showed times in the past that
when it is resolved
and when it is ready to respect a
particular mandate that it can get the
law through and that is what people
expect so IIIi have the opportunity to
talk to many of my constituents after
the vote yesterday they were I in a
mixture of despair and confusion but
Parliament which had said look we'd
prefer a deal to No Deal
when presented with a very good deal
from Parliament voted for more delay now
I know that some of those who voted for
delay yesterday I hope but they will
vote for the deal she wasn't voting for
delay she says she was voting is an
insurance policy because effectively she
doesn't trust other people in Parliament
to try and put no deal back on the table
which is what she's worried about I
understand in unrespected admire amber
but i think the most important thing
that all of us can do now is to focus on
getting the legislation through because
i think it's also important to recognize
that as a result of yesterday's vote the
risk of leaving without a deal has grown
we if we'd had our victory yesterday
would have been on a on a clear flight
path towards a deal now as a result of
that vote we can't guarantee that any
extension will be granted and therefore
I've it's my responsibility my my
departmental my constitutional
responsibility to prepare for all
eventualities the risk of leaving
without a deal has actually increased
because we cannot guarantee that the
European Council will grant an extension
and that is why I will later today be
chairing a Cabinet Committee meeting
extraordinarily on a Sunday in order to
ensure that the next stage of our exit
preparations our preparedness for No
Deal is is accelerated and what are what
does that mean in real terms it means
that we're triggering operation the
other hammer it means that we are
preparing to ensure that if no extension
is granted and we cannot guarantee than
an extension will be granted that we
have done everything possible in order
to prepare to leave without a deal and
that's why it's urgent
parliamentarians have a choice now there
is a sure thing in front of us and that
is the Prime Minister's deal that honors
the referendum mandate and if people
vote for it then we can leave and we can
leave in an orderly way but
don't vote for that deal then the risk
is that the European Council will say
that's it we're not interested in delay
you have decided not to back the deal
that we've backed and that we say is a
good deal
I'm afraid that's it do you think you
have the numbers to get it through I
believe we do yes I think that one of
the interesting things about yesterday
is that as I said I I you know I I
didn't agree with all of electron's
amendment I wish it hadn't been passed
but there are people who whom I like and
admire like amber who voted for it
I love bombing if the people who need is
controlled she's a friend as is Oliver
um and you know people can disagree this
is an issue which which raises a you
know understandable passions on every
side but I'm hopeful that a number of
people like amber who voted for all of
electron's
amendment will vote for the deal Oliver
himself has said that it's a really good
deal and he wants to have the chance to
vote for it are you at all worried that
the speaker may not allow you to bring
meaningful vote forward well these
decisions for the speaker but one thing
that term no MP can do is to prevent the
legislation coming forward which will
allow MPs to vote on the bill which will
become an act which will take us out of
the European Union and what happens if
they don't
okay well if we don't back it as I say
there's a real danger that we will leave
without a duel if we do not back this
deal then the risk the risk that we
assess and which you know I have to take
incredibly seriously advised by civil
servants is that if we do not back this
deal then the risk is that the European
Council may not grant an extension we
cannot bet on that
it is not a sure thing and therefore we
have to be ready for every eventuality
and that is why I hope because my strong
preference is for us to leave with a
deal but MPs will support the Prime
Minister you have been quite critical
about the latwon amendment but I just
wonder if part of the feeling that many
MPs have a simply haven't had time to
probably look at some incredibly
important changes that you want to make
to the future the country I mean this is
it here it is a hefty document it is 535
pages long is it not right the MP you
should have a bit more time to die
just it to read it otherwise you were
basically asking them just to trust you
we've had three and a half years since
the referendum with debates about brexit
with different models being assessed
three and a half days get to grips with
the latest changes the key changes I
think almost everyone in Parliament is
aware of or certainly should be aware of
now the key changes are this that we've
ditched the backstop that we've allowed
the the whole of the UK including
Northern Ireland to leave the customs
union and to be one customs territory
and it's also the case that in the
political declaration we've made it
clear that our ambition and this will be
the next stage of our work with the EU
is to get a comprehensive top-class
free-trade agreement but it's also clear
that we will protect workers rights and
protect the environment it's a good deal
it's clear from what overlap when Amber
rod and others have said that they
they've had a chance to look at this
deal to assess it and to say let's back
it I think that when people say we need
more time in many cases what they're
trying to do is what salmon Parliament
have tried to do throughout which is to
use delay as a way of trying to overturn
the referendum mandate now we're talking
about the detailer deal at the deal here
and I am keen to talk about what's in
the actual deal in particular in
relation to the Union and Northern
Ireland's because the DEP have some
genuine and deeply held concerns about
undermining the integrity of the Union
going forward we can just have a look at
what Sonny Wilson said in the House of
Commons yesterday now here's a de piece
brexit spokesperson he said that
Northern Ireland and Northern Ireland
alone will be left in the clutches of
the European Union and then he goes on
to say about the details of the deal if
anyone tells me that does not represent
an economic customs legal border hard
order between Northern Ireland and the
rest of the United Kingdom I don't know
what a hard border looks like then can
you understand why there are these
deeply cloud concerns and passions from
unionists yes I can I worked with Sammy
in the past we we were colleagues on the
brexit Select Committee together and
there are people who are DUP MPs who are
vine and I'm a very strong supporter of
the union of our four nations so I
completely understand how seriously my
friends and colleagues in the DPP taken
out and I think that the important thing
I believe to recognize is that there is
no change none in the constitutional
status of Northern Ireland it is the
case that we leave as one United Kingdom
there are changes will be one so I mean
you can talk about the constitutional
realities but impractical changes there
are some considerable practical
differences between Northern Ireland and
the rest of United Kingdom well there
are some specific proposals that are in
place which ie make sure that we can
safeguard the gains of the peace process
by ensuring that there is no
infrastructure at or near the border
between Northern Ireland and the Irish
Republic and it is also the case that we
can ensure that businesses in Northern
Ireland have unimpeded access to both
the UK and to Ireland so business
organisations in Northern Ireland have
welcomed to this deal they believe that
it's in the interests of the jobs and
workers of Northern Ireland and I think
that with goodwill we can make these
arrangements work in a way which gives
Northern Ireland a strong economic
underpinning and the strength of
Northern Ireland's economy the stability
of people's jobs and futures can help to
underpin the Union because the Union
ultimately is built on stability and a
shared sense that we're all in this
together and one of the things that I
know the Prime Minister and I want to do
is to show that we're reinforcing the
union at every level and that we're
making not just the investment in in
financial terms but the investment in
emotional terms to ensure that people in
Northern Ireland let people in Scotland
and Wales recognise that we are one UK
stronger together well I just look at
what the Prime Minister himself has said
on this previously himself at the DP
conference last year this is how Boris
Johnson if you like defined what the
union would be he said we would be
damaging the fabric of the union with
regulatory checks and even customs
controls between Great Britain and
northern
no British Conservative government could
or should sign up to anything of the
time of the kind under this plan there
will be regulatory checks there will be
customs checks in the Irish state and
the Prime Minister himself has defined
that as damaging the fabric of the Union
the promise was talking about past
proposals we have new proposals one of
thinking about checks and customs checks
what the iris-t my previously on this
Dale in my previous job I was
Environment Secretary and one of the
things as Environment Secretary that I
was very well aware of is that there are
already regulatory checks as my friend
colleague David Davis pointed out
earlier the Reverend Ian Paisley when he
was leader of the DUP used to say my
people are British but my cows are Irish
and by that he meant that the whole
island of Ireland was what scientists
call a single epidemiological zone in
other words there are checks when live
animals move from Scotland or from
Liverpool to Northern Ireland there are
already checks that we need to manage
but the the key question if you take one
step back is is Northern Ireland in the
customs territory the same customs
territory as the rest of the UK
absolutely is it outside the customs
union of the EU absolutely okay finally
the other thing is this deal is
underpinned by the principle of consent
it cannot be the case that Northern
Ireland can be kept in any arrangement
against its will okay now John Baron one
of the leaf voters in your party said on
Friday that you and the Foreign
Secretary had assured him that we could
still leave with no deal at the end of
the transition period nishan is that
true well we want a deal but the
alternative always if we don't get a
deal is that a no deal is there as a
real prospect that is why at the end of
the transition the government is
determined to secure a deal and in the
same way as the government and the prime
minister were told that he couldn't
secure a deal before October the 31st in
80 days the Prime Minister showed that
he could accelerate this process sheet
ouch I'm bearing that a deal
I described it what is it what is the
constitutional position and the
constitutional position is this that
beforehand with the backstory
it would have been the case that if we
didn't conclude a deal we would have
been kept in arrangements against our
will from which we could not exit we can
absolutely place it we could leave with
no net share we do not want to leave
with no deal and it is enough to appease
no it's only possible if MPs vote to
leave it No Deal and I believe MPs will
vote for the Prime Minister's deal and
for a good free-trade agreement does the
government still want an election and
when when should one be well I think we
want to get brexit done and we've argued
that actually the people need to form a
verdict on this Parliament and I think
when an election comes it will be an
opportunity for people to both our
affect on who's been trying to deliver
brexit and who's been seeking to thwart
it went and also the people priorities
that's about for the Prime Minister but
when do you think it should be that is a
matter for the Prime Minister when he
asks my advice I offer it but it's a
decision for the Prime Minister and
ultimately for Parliament so do you
think it should still be before
Christmas he's still pushing for an
election at the earliest possible
opportunity or phyllis diller pastures
does that not at the moment my eyes are
completely on getting this deal done and
preparing for life outside the European
Union Deal or No Deal that is my
absolute top priority I know of course
it is the case that but we need a I
believe is strong conservative majority
in the House of Commons to ensure that
the Queen's speech that we've outlined
which will mean more investment in the
police more investment in education and
more investment in our NHS it's
comprehensive backing but at the moment
the single most important thing is for
all of us whatever our views about the
general election whether we're levers
will remain as labour or conservative to
recognize that we are Democrats first
and the British people sent us a clear
instruction three and a half years ago
and above all else it is now time to
deliver if you don't deliver by the 31st
of October should the Prime Minister
resign we're going to deliver by the
31st of October we are going to ensure
that we get this deal done and I'm
confident that with the support of good
people with whom we may have disagreed
in the past but who respect democracy we
will get this deal done if you're
betting now would you put money on up
yes I have
you have okay how much well that's
between me and the health secretary